that was some truthy ass truthy ass weed
anyway please please please do i will
sit here and get a little more
irresponsibly stoned okay this is a
shitty idea
and so there's a bunch of these bosons
these are particles that carry these
forces and interact with these forces
that basically hold all matter together
that gives
any of this [ __ ] any kind of shape and
ultimately physicists cosmologists most
scientists really uh their whole job is
to just try and answer that question
what the [ __ ] is any of this [ __ ] still
that question is unanswered probably
unanswerable i don't think our
scientists will ever
actually know any of these answers
it just seems like
impossible god anytime i start thinking
about [ __ ] particle physics i'm just
like what's the point of any of this
anyway
uh
anyway
the w buzz
the w boson
is
this particle that governs the weak
nuclear force and up until
basically a month or so ago
they thought many scientists thought
that they had like accurate measurements
of that particle's mass
but some data had come out or i guess
they crunched the numbers on this data
they've been laying around for a minute
finally finished the analysis and they
found out that it has more mass than
they thought or at least there is now an
accurate measurement that claims that
but it contradicts some prior
measurements if
it is accurate it will mean
that the standard model of particle
physics makes a little less sense
which means we might have some [ __ ]
wrong
and that means we need to start looking
at new ways to decipher what the [ __ ]
this [ __ ] is dude and anytime we get to
one of those new plateaus where it's
like oh [ __ ] some [ __ ] we thought was
right may not be right it forces us to
look deeper find out new [ __ ] this is
like when we thought it was a [ __ ]
heliocentric universe uh or sorry a
[ __ ] earth-centered universe not
heliocentric
and everybody's like no [ __ ]
we're actually spinning around the sun
and everybody's like what the [ __ ] then
they thought it was heliocentric and
they're like okay but the universe
revolves around the sun right no
[ __ ] we're one tiny [ __ ]
solar system in a galaxy of solar
systems in a universe of [ __ ]
galaxies billions and billions [ __ ]
you've heard girls
i knew you were gonna light years away i
knew you're gonna break out carl sang
kermit the frog think of how senseless
kermit feeling of the rivers of blood
yeah dude
on one side of this tiny do it yoda
sagan it's the same thing billions and
billions billions
billion billion
billions and
billions and billions of years what is
that yoda saying billions and billions
well you got yoda and kermit sagan are
both similar i think from you yeah
they're so they sound like why are there
so many yeah dude
things before boson
and what's the
there aren't
see this is the whole [ __ ] deal when
you start getting into particle physics
here's what you're really looking for
tiny
you want the argument
how did this [ __ ] all happen
why are there particles at all it's like
we can find new subatomic particles and
get better measurements of their [ __ ]
mass but
still watch why is there any of this
[ __ ] what made it and if we are a
[ __ ] simulation
does that even [ __ ] matter
because then what made the [ __ ]
simulation and who made those [ __ ]
people brother it just doesn't matter
german hogan all that said i do love new
scientific discoveries they are exciting
it is [ __ ] exciting
yeah
new scientific discoveries yeah hold on
a second look
i can have my stogy whatever i want
nothing like you dude listen your
schwarzenegger's another one that
[ __ ] kills me yeah any time
i thought of something the other day i
just started hearing your voice of
schwarzenegger saying
two words
voodoo and hulu
voodoo
voodoo
hulu
[Laughter]
a little juice in there that is not
accurate but it's [ __ ] hilarious well
here we go
you
it's his austrian accent because he goes
you know while he goes he would be like
yeah voodoo voodoo
put in that little like you do
what voodoo
right no no
yeah it's like this
this is how you say
voodoo hulu you say it's very simple all
you have to do to say it
is is all you say is voodoo hulu yeah
you do one word
then the other word even you said we are
the noses
but these are words
hulu
oh that [ __ ] [ __ ] cracks me up dude
and again that's one that i've heard
probably equal to hulk hogan
and uh it just never gets old to me i
don't know what the [ __ ] it is it's that
weird little like character you put in
there yeah uh so
hey the w bosom
yep did any of that [ __ ] make sense to
you whatsoever uh no dude i'm [ __ ]
baked now oh so nope
no way man but i don't understand like
i literally am like this is the worst
way to do this
because
let me tell you let me tell you a little
something about let me just let me just
tell you this
please this here's the thing
i when we hang out
and we watch like movies you know we'll
have we'll smoke a little grass and
watch a movie and we'll do some hanging
out we'll catch up with our pals and
then i will i'll tear off in a story and
then as you like to say and it's it's an
accurate description of what i do
well i just give all sorts of back
uh details you don't need and then i go
on some tangents start talking about
like some weird [ __ ] thing that you
did in high school also usually stories
that we've all heard literally 500 times
for sure all of them yeah so that's
going to be this show two dudes
thank you moving on you're welcome
doozy here's what you do
please tell a friend and break it review
if you'd like to see here's what you do
please tell a friend then break a review
if you like dudes here's what you do
please tell a friend then